well projection is of course the
defining fact of the modern left on
virtually every issue they attack their
opponents as what they are they call
them racist even as they denounce half
the country for its skin color Kansas
Queen Victoria Canada Kris Kobach is the
latest person to learn that lesson the
hard way over at Sina and Jeffrey Toobin
says that because he dislikes Kobach's
views Quebec is of course a bigot here's
part of it kris has devoted his career
to stopping black people and poor people
from voting I mean that's been your goal
for decades that and and then outrageous
accusation completely track chilly out
rageous accusation so you so if you are
if you like photo ID you're trying to
stop people of color from voting
absolute is outrageous lutely Kris
Kobach joins us tonight
Kris thanks all for coming on so what is
there an argument that and we've done
this topic a couple of times but I don't
I don't fully understand it so the idea
is what you just said if you're trying
to make certain that people vote legally
and ask for ID that's an act of bigotry
what is the like flesh out that argument
if you would I don't understand it the
argument itself is a racist one the
argument is that somehow because of your
skin color you are less likely to have
in your wallet a photo ID or you're less
likely to be able to go to a government
office and get a free photo ID
it's a ridiculous argument it's been
disproven empirically in state after
state but the hard left and now
increasingly the entire left keeps
making the argument and you know Tucker
I went into that debate that program
thinking we're gonna have a cordial
debate about birthright citizenship but
as soon as Jeffrey Toobin started losing
the argument he just out of the blue
says well you've devoted your career to
stopping people of color from voting
it's crazy you're I mean since ID and is
required from everything I mean you
can't cash your paycheck you're taking
an airplane you can't stay in a hotel or
rent a car I mean right and kick it into
buildings without an ID so why does no
one ever call those laws racist I wonder
well because maybe they aren't racist
and maybe it's not racist for your bank
to insist on an ID when you cash a check
but of course they they pull this out of
nowhere and they don't realize the
inconsistency that you just pointed
and that my my twelve-year-old daughter
could have pointed out to them they just
you know it must be racist never mind
that it's an incoherent statement I
wonder I mean this prominent the first
time you've been attacked this way and
and the presumption is that the person
attacking you knows what you think is
somehow has x-ray vision and can see
your heart yeah and feelings are which
is insane
but beyond that it has kind of short
circuit and a rational conversation
about the integrity of our elections
hasn't it it absolutely has I mean now
even to suggest that voter fraud exists
which it does and we've prosecuted many
cases in my office as Secretary of State
in Kansas yeah to even suggest that it
exists is racist just like they've
short-circuited the immigration debate
if you want to enforce our laws you must
be a racist if you want to stop the
caravan you must be a racist I mean it's
it does it just cuts off the debate
completely when you attack the person
making the other argument I tried to buy
sudafed for my kids a couple years ago
at CBS and and they wouldn't sell it to
me because I didn't have an ID I'm
waiting for people to pick it CBS four
it's racist suit of house
I think that'll happen I don't hold your
breath
Thank You secretary thank you very much